3 es geht sind willkommen zu einem neuen
video leute heute werden max und ich
maximus mein bruder mein gott ja magst
du nicht werden heute testen wer von uns
der beste bruder ist das heißt während
den anderen besser kennt jeder von uns
fünf vorbereitet persönliche fragen
wollen selbst ich über mich und dich
dann gegenseitig durchgehend das heißt
sie stellen mag es meine fragen stellst
du mir deine fragen und dann schauen wir
wer am ende die meisten fahrer richtig
beantwortet hat der verlierer kommen
nicht ungeschoren davonkommt einen
besondern die bestrafen und heutigen
tage verwirkt sich hier drin das ist ein
auseinandergehen diesem genial ist jetzt
noch gar nichts ich werde das jetzt aber
zu jahn ergeben und jana darf eine
mischung drei machen die wir beide nicht
sehen werden okay wir bekommen nach ihr
dieses all video der verlierer musste
ich dieses mit voll schmackes gegen die
stirn
lieberman roulette nur das finde ich
dass das endlich beginnen und nene drei
meiner grundschule von baugrundstücken
übernahmen tom feuerstein die geht aber
nur einer der pressevertreter und wir
haben getötet und 32 wollte ja kein plan
b oder die story dazu gedreht haben war
das natürlich die truppe von max haben
ihm geschildert einfach maxus ec karte
geklaut im alter von sieben jahren ist
dieser mann gewachsen ist jetzt nicht
gerade geld dafür kann man sich
normalerweise eher weniger wie ich es
das erste mädchen das ich verliebt war
juli ab ich würde ihn vorne wissen sie
heute aber ja woher weißt du das ja
immer beim pflücken
zu nehmen weil sie als die teams
teilnahmen geschrieben communications
data in einer krise sind zunächst welche
körperteile habe ich mir schon mal
eingebrochen schwanz saas-lösung
ausgebrochen
verdammt ja wohl jeder hätte es
natürlich mitbekommen eigentlich dumm
was aber die meisten menschen brechen
sich ihren kleinen zeh und es jemals zu
merken
alles klar in welcher klasse wäre ich
hass sitzen geblieben
okay das oft über die 10 tut mir leid
denn ernst zehnte der 88 doch es war die
achte damit leider falsch passend dazu
meine nächste frage welches schuljahr
musste ich wiederholen
ich weiß nicht dass in der vergangenheit
öfters mal probleme mit der frage
hattest zum beispiel so ist wirklich der
damals stets nach zu finden ok was war
mein schlechtestes aviv ein schlechtes
händchen dafür gründer drin dann
schlecht das ist dass hier herr spannend
sehr schlechte note in der prüfung
gegeben hat aber ich weiß natürlich ein
schlechtes ist
die aktion aber ganz gut dass ich sagen
wirtschaft und recht richtig gruselig
war klären wirtschaft und recht wie so
eine miese note möglich nachdem er
studiert wirtschaft du verdammter
abgewickelter miese als nächstes ist
eine frage die die person des krans
betritt welches mal eine youtube videos
hat als erstes eine million views
erreicht das ja wie viele jetzt an die
weitaus erstes mit einer millionen fast
so mittlerweile runtergenommen pokémon
black and opened wie achten
dieses eine trockene haut trägt wenn man
kennen muss ja das habe ich erst nicht
runter genommen und zweitens war das
erste was man mir erreicht habt größte
sneakers der welt
hier könnt ihr konnte ist es nicht
vergessen eindruck hier steht 2 2
zu zwei spielen drei damit nichts frage
wo ich mein erster autounfall war ich
glaube dass ich war auf der autobahn von
münchen und nach hause
gerade aus münchen heraus gefahren ist
neben der eine eingepennt und erste
reifen geplatzt bei der feier fand
leider war das vor münchen mit
das gesagt was macht ihr großen spaß
ja und da wird man punkt das heißt jetzt
kommt die letzte frage diese lautet
welches tier war mein lieblings
kuscheltier als ich ganz nett jeder sony
profitierten felix haase letzte frage
von mir warum wurde ich von der abfahrt
ausgeschlossen
beide trugen dazu aufgerufen hat eine
staatsaufgabe eine schriftliche prüfung
zu boykottieren weil sonst nein gesagt
als sie die fotos gemacht und schreibt
nicht gibt's nicht ab falls das richtig
falsch thorsten weiter es war ein spaß
ist eigentlich mussten wir dafür punkt
geben ja das möchte ich haben wir das
andere noch nachgetragen eigentlich war
bei es waren mehrere gründe
beim schweden stattfinden wird schwierig
sein papier
[Musik]
es war der partner war wurde ich hatte
ja bitte diese bestrafung hast du schon
das minischwein nachricht nämlich meinen
neuen marktstudie heute neues merger 15
also ich könnte das nicht ab das kommt
15 da kann ich den kopf und haben diese
drei
nur noch ist aus teterow wallstreet er
auch schokolade und waging leute heute
etwas andere ab und wie gesagt man
möchte am 15 11
haltet euch dafür bereit hier könne man
kann aber die wird sich noch was geht
sebastian budig bestes geben ich sonst
nicht mehr ab